hallo mein name ist khan und ich mache
einen test auf der akinator seite wir
kennen ja ganz normal akinator web genie
und diese kleine serie ja und dann haben
wir hier die ganz normalen fragen hier
die ganz normalen antworten was ich
allerdings heute versuchen möchte ist
dass ich versuche die längste akinator
runde zu machen die es je gab
dafür habe ich jetzt einfach mal gesagt
dass ich die ganze zeit ja nein ich
weiss nicht wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich nicht drücken werde
und da wieder von vorne nein ich weiss
nicht wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
nicht ja nein ich weiss nicht
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich nicht ja
nein ich weiss nicht wahrscheinlich
dieser verdammte ritter der kokosnuss
kommt jedes verdammte mal ich weiß nicht
ob ihr euch noch an irgendeine der
letzten folgen ändern könnte
ich glaube das war das vor drei folgen
da habe ich auch irgendwas richtiges
gesucht und auf einmal kommt der ritter
der kokosnuss alle den kommentaren
ich führe allerdings weiterhin mein test
hier vor ort ja nein ich weiss nicht
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich nicht
tana french eingereicht von dsl films
ist eine schriftstellerin erst mal
schauen was diese geschrieben hat anna
freilich hat unter anderem faithfull
place brocken habe sigrid place der ganz
schön viel geschrieben allerdings ist
sie das auch nicht und wir machen weiter
mit unserem nein ich weiss nicht
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich nicht in
irgend einer von euch zockern ich spiele
ja selber nicht so aus welchem spiel ist
der ich würd mal so groß sagen dass der
aus metin2 ist oder aus world of
warcraft weil dass sie beides so aus
aber ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung
nein das ist er allerdings auch nicht
denn wir waren weiter mit ja nein ich
weiss nicht wahrscheinlich spätestens
jetzt ist der moment gekommen wo ich
sage nein nein ich bin raus wir haben
hier ein zebra fand was ist ein zebra
fand ich würde so gern wissen wie oft
der zebra fand schon gespielt wurde aber
ich muss leider auf nein und auf ja
klicken und es geht weiter mit ist eine
figur war zwei meter gross und ich muss
leider auf ja klicken spiel der hilfe
von minecraft mit nein ich weiß nicht
was ich denke an nn imas nein als
nächstes der hieraus gekommen es ist ein
typ der immer zockt ein kluger typ der
zufällig antwortet ich antworte nicht
zufällig ich antworte immer an einem
schema du grad
wir sind gerade an dem punkt angekommen
wo wenn sie die figur an die sie dachten
in der folgenden liste sehen bitte
klicken sie auf ihren namen hier stehen
jetzt verschiedene figuren zum beispiel
ein typ der immer zog das monster unter
dem bett des play prüfte von apple ob
pictures ich sage einfach meine figur
ist nicht in der liste habe ich es
durchgespielt jetzt ich schreibe jetzt
einfach mal beim namen hin ja nein ich
weiss nicht wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich nicht so abschicken
meine figur sondern ich in der liste
doch hat ihn am main geben ja nein
vielleicht typ r drückt immer in der
gleichen reihenfolge das bin ich ich
drücke aber noch wahrscheinlich und
wahrscheinlich nicht dazu also meine
figuren nicht in der liste offenbar
kenne ich deine figur noch nicht um die
figur zuzufügen beschädige bitte den
namen ek patina tor durchgespielt die
beschreibung die dazu figuren mit
gleichen namens zu unterscheiden
beispiel hin reduziert
könig von england name ja nicht gleich
wahrscheinlich beschreibungen jemand der
alle fünf antworten in der gleichen
reihenfolge wiederholt anklickt so
abschicken und beschreibung seite
zwischen 52 buchstaben liegen ein cooler
typ wenn du das zu blöd haben willst
abschicken bravo sie haben eine falle
gestellt
es ist offiziell ich hab ihn ich habe
dass ich habe den akinator besiegt ich
kann jetzt aufspielen wieder klicken
dann bin ich wieder ganz normal hier bei
den sachen ich suche jetzt mal einfach
nicht selber nochmal ja ja ist let's
play es bei o2 dabei trägt ein langes
haar eines nicht zeiten mit theo koll
crafter ja ich höre auf ich gehe die
frage ist deine figur kompakter kam
schon jetzt kommt kommt deine figur aus
kay group roger ich jetzt hat doch schon
gesagt dass ich crafter bilden deswegen
an dieser stelle meine lieben freunde
das war es mit diesem video wenn es euch
gefallen hat wie ich mich über die
bewertung freund ich habe quasi jetzt
gerade die längste mögliche runde
akinator gespielt und ihm quasi eine
falle gestellt wollt ihr noch mehr
akinator oder sagt dir langsam so 8
dann überlege ich mir meine neue serie
obwohl ich schon eine richtig gute idee
habe und damit meine ich diese studie
die idee weil dies mehr so ein bisschen
zu aufwendig das ganze im schnitt das
zufällig mal das video hier vorne das
hat mich im schnitt 6 5 tage
ich hab da für die zukunft auf jeden
fall noch ein geiler let's play
vorschlag da muss ich nur noch die
berechtigung kriegen von dem hersteller
und dann sehen wir uns vielleicht in
einem anderen projekt wieder oder
akinator auf falsche ideen was wir
machen könnte